or on problem 51 and they say a diagram
from the proof or from a proof of the
pythagorean theorem is pictured below
they said they say which statement would
not be used in the proof of the
pythagorean theorem since they've drawn
this diagram out i think we might as
well just kind of do the proof and then
we can look at their choices and see
which ones kind of match up to what we
did hopefully hopefully they do it the
same way
so and this this is a pretty neat proof
of the pythagorean pythagorean theorem i
don't think i've done it yet so i might
as well do it now so the way they've
drawn it the big insight here is well
let's figure out what the area of this
large square is right well there's two
ways to think about it you could just
say okay this is a square that's a
that's b well this is going to be b as
well this is going to be a as well
so the area of this square is going to
be the length of one of its sides
squared
right so we could say a plus b the whole
square's area is a plus b squared a plus
b
squared and that's equal to
a squared plus two
a b
plus b squared
fair enough now we can also say that the
area of this larger square it's a bit of
an optical illusion it looks like it's
tilted to the left because of the way
it's drawn but anyway that the area of
this larger square is also the area of
these four triangles
plus the area of this smaller square
so this the area of the larger square
which we figured out just by taking the
taking one side of it and squaring it
that should be equal to the area of the
four smaller triangles so there's four
of them
and what's the area of each of them
let's see it's one half base let's just
pick this one one half base times height
so it's one half
times a times b
a b
so one half a b is one of these and i
multiplied it by four to get all four of
these triangles
and then we want to add the area of this
inside this inside square and that's
just going to be c squared right this
side is c that side is c so plus
c squared and let's see if we can
simplify this
so
you get a squared
a squared plus two a
b
plus b squared is equal to four times
one half is
two a
b
plus c squared
well we can subtract 2 a b from both
sides of this equation right
the top and the bottom of this equation
the way i've written it
but if we do that
you get subtract 2a b from there
subtract 2ab from there and you're left
with
a squared plus b squared is equal to
c squared which is the pythagorean
theorem and we've proved it so let's see
which of their choices
matches what we did okay which statement
would not be used in the proof of the
pythagorean theorem the area of a
triangle equals one half a b
no we used that
we had to use that the four
right triangles are congruent now we
used that
the area of the inner square
is equal to half of the area of the
larger square no we didn't use that i
think this is the one that
would not be using the proof let's see
choice d the area of the larger square
is equal to the sum of the squares of
the smaller square
and the four congruent triangles no
that's that was the crux of the of the
proof so we definitely use that so c is
our answer that's the statement that
would not be used in the proof
and i i'm learning to copy and paste
ahead of time
so i don't waste your time all right
a right triangle's hypotenuse has length
five if one leg has length two what is
the length of the other leg
okay so this is
so it's 5
2 and they want to know the other leg
pythagorean theorem x squared
plus 2 squared is equal to 5 squared
because 5 is the hypotenuse
x squared plus 4 is equal to
25 subtract 4 from both sides
x squared is equal to 21.
so x
is equal to the square root of 21.
choice b
next question
a new pipeline is being constructed to
reroute
oil flow around the exterior of a
national
wildlife preserve i guess that's the
national wildlife preserve the plan
showing the old pipeline and the new
route is shown below
okay
how many extra miles will the oil flow
once the new route is established so the
new route they you know the new route is
going to be 60 miles plus 32 miles so
the new route
is 92 miles so what was the old route
well the old route was a hypotenuse of
this triangle right
that was the old route so we could say
60 let's call that x
60 squared
plus 32
squared is equal to
is equal to x
squared
because that's the hypotenuse and these
numbers that's that's that's a bit of a
pain to
to uh
to deal with maybe i can if i can factor
out something here i could make it more
interesting so i don't have to multiply
out 60 squared and 32 squared and and
all of the ra well let me let me just
let me see if i could if i
if i factored out both of those are
divisible by
4. right both of those are divisible by
and so then i would have 15 and 8.
yeah that still doesn't make it that
that useful
so i'll just multiply them out so this
is 3 600
60 squared is 3600 and 32 squared let's
see 32 times 32
2 times 32 is 64.
3 times 2 is
6. 3 times 3 is 9.
so it's 4 12 10 24
plus 10
24 is equal to x squared
so let me just switch both sides x
squared is equal to 3 600 plus 10 24 is
and let me see if i can get an
approximate
let's see 20 times so x is going to be
the square root of this looking this
thing right here
so let's see if i can get a handle at
least on on the magnitude of where this
would be
so 50 times
24 times 24 that's you know 20 times 20
is 400 so this is way too small
60 times 60 is 3600
so 68 times 68 this looks right
especially because 8 times 8 should end
in a 4. let me try that out
68 times 68 8 times 8 is 64.
8 times 6 is 48 plus 6 is 54.
6 times 8 48
6 times 6 36 plus 4 is 40.
so 4
12 6 46 24 right so x is 68
so x is equal to 68 oh and you know what
i use 68 i shouldn't have
because they want to know they don't
want to know how long was the old
pipeline that's 68. it just happened to
be one of the choices that's just to
make sure that you read the question
properly but they want to know how much
longer is going to be the new
the new pipeline right so the new one
was
and the old one is 68 and good thing
they had that number there so i could
try it out that was the square root of
46 24.
so how much longer is a new one
well 92
minus 68
what that's 24 miles
right
92 minus 68
yeah 24 says choice a
not choice b b is how long the old
pipeline was but we want to know how
much longer the new route is
that was tricky well not tricky but
i kind of fell for it
by forgetting what the question was
about anyway next question
marcia is using a straight edge in
compass to do the construction below
interesting
which best describes the construction
marsha is doing so
i assume when they say construction
there she's drawing something
and let's see what it looks like it
looks like she's taking her compass
she's probably putting one of the points
here
she put one of the points there and then
she kind of drew this arc
and then it looks like she put the point
there and then she drew that arc
and then she put the point here and drew
that arc
and then put the point there
and drew
that arc
and the end result it seems like you
know the line the reason why she picked
this point here is it goes through this
line l
so she's probably trying to find another
point here
so that she can draw another line
because they say she has a straight edge
the straight edges to draw these lines
the compass is to draw these curves so
she were to draw another line between
these two points
if she were to draw another line between
those two points if it looks something
like that
something like that
then she would have parallel lines and
the reason why i should have parallel
lines is because these would be
corresponding angles and they would be
congruent and so if you have a
transversal the corresponding angles are
congruent you're dealing with parallel
lines
so my read of this question is that
she's probably trying to draw a line
that is parallel to l
a line through p parallel to line l yeah
that's what i think she's trying to do
all right choice a
given
and given angle a so given this angle
what is the first step in constructing
the angle
bisector
of angle a
what is the first step in constructing
the angle
bisector
okay so and and this is you know
actually i've never done this but i can
assume that if i have a compass you know
what a compass is it has those two
points one of them is like a you know
it's like a pivot point it looks
something like this
it looks
like you know has a little pivot point
and then on the other side you can stick
your pencil
and the bottom line is and you can you
can adjust it up here
at the bottom you pivot around this and
then you can draw circles
of arbitrary radiuses right it seems
like what that's what they did here so
if i wanted to draw the angle bisector
of a
i'm just thinking about it it seems i
could put the pivot point here
and then i can put the pencil and i can
draw this circle
i can draw the circle and really as long
as i just
you know find the two points that it
intersects those two lines or those two
rays then i'll be fine and i could i
could have done it anywhere i could have
done it here
i could have done it out here and they
just picked points b and c and then from
each of those points you can put up you
could put your pivot here
if you put your pivot here and then you
would draw a circle around that you
would have gotten this one right here
right and then if you were to put your
pivot point around here and draw a
circle you would be able to draw that
and then when they intersect
that would that would give you an
indication of where the angle bisector
is right and you could then draw that
line to where they intersect
so let's see they say what is the first
step in constructing the angle bisector
of angle a so they say draw a d ray a d
well no that seems like that would be
the
the last step then you're done right
draw a d that is the angle bisector
draw a line segment connecting points b
and c
a line segment no that's useful i mean
you use lists you don't need a line
segment i mean this even what they have
drawn that's an arc it's not a line
from points b and c draw equal arcs that
intersect at d
that was the second step i mean you have
to have points b and c before you can
draw those equal arcs
from point a draw an arc that intersects
the side of the angle at points b and c
at points b
and c yeah that's what we said that was
the first step put your pivot here and
draw use your pencil to draw this arc
and you say okay this point this point
so that would be the first step
d
and oh i'm all out of problems and i'm
out of time see in the next video